hello guys I'm Ryan right yeah you're
gonna watch us react today to what I
think is just an audio prank call gone
horribly wrong I love prank calling it's
so fun I once called the church and I
was like there's a bomb in your building
and one of your altar server boys are
tied up right now and I'm gonna kill him
wow that's dark it's so funny it was so
fun it was hilarious
were you by yourself they really liked
the SWAT team game day and um they had
to shut the whole church down they
burned it so funny I encourage all of
you to pull pranks like that
hey a big Kanye West fan you've heard us
do a false confession before so here's
the thing today okay we're gonna have
fun with you you know I hopefully you
have somebody that you can do I asked
for a wrong either uh lens and a pause
bender guys an F oh why is he calling
this is what today know what Friday we
did the girl that had to come out to her
grandma on if she's still loved her and
accepted her that she would get the
tickets to the judge but we do that okay
that was that was easy you're gonna have
to call your husband do you guys have
kids yeah possibly there's a guy he's
good okay perfect
he's nine years old yeah okay you're
gonna have to call your husband all
right oh I know it's gonna be tough uh
but you know it's for the tickets is he
a big Kanye fan maybe this will help too
if he's a Kanye fan it will be able to
easier to explain down yeah you like it
anyway more but he does like him too
thank God good so this'll be a lot
easier to explain to him though you know
if he's into this like honey we get to
go to the show see it was all a game
okay so you have to explain them that
your son what's your son's name nine
years old yep Robin you have to explain
that Logan little Logan is
not actually your husband son he's not
you can explain that
okay my head and he doesn't use a cuss
word or if he doesn't you know flip out
and just completely become unhinged
you'll get two tickets he has to say
that you have to get him to say I still
love you in the sense to love you and I
want to be with you I want to be this
child's father I've been I didn't saw
that for nine years only continue if you
can get him to do that you'll get two
tickets to Kanye I know what okay even
when you take your chances on this do
you think you who is it that does is he
pretty sure that he's the father of you
guys ever had any discussion about that
you know at one time we did have my dad
yeah that's how kind of sticking out but
I think I can get them as a going to say
angry at you why you seem to think that
this is gonna work out you got a husband
I asked for somebody who's married you
guys have a little kid look boy how old
is he nice what's his neck okay good now
you're gonna tell your husband husband
stain okay I got the number here we're
gonna call Pete here and now the false
confessions work we did it we had a good
old tell her grandma that she was
getting she was coming out but I know
how to say oh I still love you if she
could get her to grandmother's say I
love you and not cause it's more your
career with that it's not set up we got
we've been monitoring you you're not we
could talk to you you're not like
calling him or whatever so we're
convincing she doesn't know then now you
won the tickets but you have to be able
to tell him listen Logan is not yours
you're not the father okay
not only is he not the father but you
had to get here the car acceptor so he's
came up to you and be sure to get headed
our three minutes
oh my god okay then you got the tips on
interesting job it's an upside-down met
for the hey what y'all saying up take
man they caught with me now as soon as
as soon as i dial this and the phone
starts ringing you're gonna be on your
own okay okay I think you could handle
this I got it yeah everything else guys
it on your dad before my husband piece
of me no texting either yeah yeah when
she can't text while she's on you're on
your own self yeah I want to do this
room okay tickets maybe like money
you're on your own you okay we go honey
parish hey woody doing must've happened
then it's not to you forsaken are you
busy yeah good okay I just wanted to
talk to you about something kind of
serious that I've let you know okay are
you somewhere where you can like I'm
interested okay okay what's up looking
so um I just I feel like you know we've
been married a while and we're raising
our son together and I just want to be
completely honest with you and I feel
like there's a lot that I've been
keeping from you when I I just want a
relationship to always be strong and I
just wanna I just really want to be
honest with you honey and I'm scared to
death I feel like I want to be able to
tell you anything and then not have you
leave me and it's just okay you're
acting really really strange right now
Andrew I know I know what is your
festering about some fairly serious I
just want to make sure that we're on the
same page because you always want to be
honest with you outside oh there's a
couple things that we talked about you
know about nine years ago and welcome
was born and you wanted to know for sure
that
if he was your son because you've had
some questions about a co-worker oh I
told you that we were just you know
friends and stuff and I just I really
want to be honest with you honey he's
he's not yours and that's the only
reason why I bring in this not this
because Logan's getting older and I just
want to raise him in an atmosphere where
there's two parents that love him and
trust each other and let's have
everything on the table are you are you
sure you something right now yeah yeah I
don't know when you say these are just
using a new google of you and I just I
really want to be honest with you just
explain it to me I understand this is so
so nine years ago
even my back toward was of me uh Frank
the guard used to work with you guys
working together the thing is that there
was nothing there I mean I was
completely wasted at an office party and
there's nothing there and I'm dead
serious
I don't even I don't even talk to you
anymore it's very uncomfortable I can't
I can't stand to be in the same room
with them and I don't I don't do I don't
believe you right now I believe in you
call me up on a random in the Moines a
to tell me this are you insane no honey
please I just I really want to be unreal
to me what would we have you 50 to react
to [ __ ] I know that you'll be mad I'm
hoping that we can work this out are you
are you what are you crazy
we work this out you tell you call me up
at work so God's sakes tell me that my
son's not mine honey I know I know it's
weird timing
oh I going through her head right now I
just feel like if I didn't tell you
because I was it was on my mind if I
didn't just get it out that I wouldn't
ever tell you and I just wanted to like
I really wanted to be honest I just
wanted to get it out as soon as possible
that's fine so that's that that's that's
what we're doing today we're just kind
of confessing everything about it
I just honey I'm telling you it's just
been on my mind because I love you and I
want I want to be honest with you I'll
be honest with you you too I'm sleeping
with
the past year okay there so that's what
we're doing today I mean it was funny I
know that you're upset also Kanye gently
if that's what we're doing we're being
completely honest go ahead ask a co-op
cover story on a Pete I'm surprising you
your eye is putting plans on that W as
an axe you you're on the yellow in was
calling you for on Kanye West a serious
there is everything to see Kanye he
could tell me are you serious yes or no
I was just joking with you to get Kanye
West tickets please you tell me that
you're just joking are you just saying
that because you're upset
oh no I'm on the radio right now no yeah
you really sleeping with your sister
Peter disgusting you're sick I was just
kidding with you because I was try and
get honey West because you should be
with my sister that's even worse than
sleeping with some co-worker that's like
disgusting you can't be sticking you
know what you have to say normal that
come back cause I don't think I want to
be under the same roof with you I really
don't want to be interesting with you
this is nice what a great Valentine's
Day gift I was trying to get a hunt are
you are you beat are used are you
serious you don't know me I'm not I'm
not talking about the fun over here hey
Wow did not expect it to go down that
path that was shocking shocking first
off - shocking - shocking I wouldn't
pull a prank like that for some concert
tickets
that's traumatizing someone it is so
messed up I mean if she was like babe no
we just got a hundred grand like I
called you at work made you flip out
like destroyed your life for a little
bit for a hundred grand no no for Connie
tickets and he doesn't even really like
Kanye yeah you know it's so messed up
sleeping with this sister Oh
man I've only seen that kind of [ __ ] on
like the Maury show and it's yeah that's
a greater than like worse on a sister's
part if you like oh yeah totally I mean
I could see from a guy perspective like
oh you sleep with the sister that's hot
because she's a girl
that's still like so icky like I don't
get how they can ever make their
relationship work
oh yeah I can only not sleep with a
sibling god no if Veronica did anything
women are you listening apni you
listening Anthony you've a brother you
have a brother one hmm
how old is he uh 31 well yeah don't look
at him okay it's a lot thinner than me
is it he's like full brother yeah yeah
yeah anyway I know people who had
somewhat like found out that like
someone they loved or someone they were
with slept with her sibling yeah a
relationship was pretty much doomed you
know it's like it's unfortunate but she
deserved to know that like she does yeah
she deserved to know the truth so that
way this chick it an it's an
embarrassing that had happened so
publicly but he looks like the bad guy
I'd imagined that some people might take
the guy side being like well she was an
idiot it was [ __ ] up for her to call
on the radio and stuff but I'm like nah
come on man the real bad person is the
guy like she was playing a mean joke but
he was doing something incredibly cruel
and traumatizing to this woman she's
losing her man and now she probably has
lost her relationship with her sister
and she probably won't want to go see
Kanye now and now ship her and now the
on table reminder of depression from all
this [ __ ] yeah then everything has been
ruined for her no more gold digger no
more gold digger or jesus walks I'm
still on like Kanye from like 10 years
ago I wouldn't even take free Conny
tickets like right now let alone ruin my
life for what so one thing to those
presenters were [ __ ] douches yeah
like they were cracking up at what a
horrible situation is like ratings like
if I was in that situation as the host I
would have been like guys I am so sorry
for making this a public yeah
joke you guys have to handle this I
wouldn't be like really dude did you
really
oh no I know I agree hey guys thanks for
sending that our way that was delightful
it really was sure and has really made
me paranoid about my future well we
listen to the radio yeah if you guys are
new to the channel you can subscribe
today become a what reducta titus well
you already did it Titus well reject
annoyed reject annoyed damn Danielle
you're good at this she's not hemorrhoid
projecting oi and we are looking for
sponsorship from hemorrhoids we want to
help people with hemorrhoids it's not a
fun disease it's not a fun disease it
deals with your butt
I didn't want to learn much more than
that but all I know is it's a serious
issue and I'm starting up a foundation
for people with hemorrhoids so hey hey
no I do give a very like small range of
thing and you could check out Danielle's
Instagram where sexy photos will come
soon coming soon coming soon get it I
get it yeah cuz they're gonna come soon
to your photos domestic violence what
the kid yeah domestic violence funny
topic area can't wait for the comic book
no joke about domestic violence well
then don't watch damn watch